[Music]
[Applause]
happy thursday everyone i'm so excited
because it's time for
[Music]
you
[Music]
with your host joy behar
yes welcome to hug your thug where
victims and their victimizers come
together to see who the real criminal is
i'm your host host joy behar
first let's address a socialist
candidate for the city council tiffany
caban who admitted admitted increase in
violent crimes and shootings wants
victims of violent crimes to work with
their attackers attackers in the name of
restorative justice
by the way if you see a word in front of
justice other than criminal you know
you're getting a dose of leftist
nonsense
legit justice requires law and order
something lefties hate more than soap
and water
caban calls it a public safety plan but
for whom exactly bringing the victim
together with the perp who brutally
beats her this is like the world's
weirdest dating app
so how did you two lovebirds meet oh he
pistol-whipped me under a bridge in
central park stole my purse and then
drove off in my car
kabon calls it a public safety plan
that's about as safe as dining with the
taliban and asking for kosher options
that's about as safe as a second
audition with harvey weinstein
that's about as safe as wearing a donut
suit around brian stelter
obviously this is meant to strip cops in
courts of any authority and give more
power to hard left activists who never
met a criminal they didn't like
here's part of her proposal quote
example of use a person is beat up
suffers a broken rib and is robbed of
his of his wallet first his needs are
heard and affirmed and he works with
trained staff to develop a services and
healing plan
first of all thanks for assuming the
gender of the crime victim
shouldn't it be their wallet i would
only hope that the victim fills out a
pronoun's worksheet while he's still
bleeding in the street
it keeps going
then when he is ready he participates in
restorative justice circles with the
person who harmed him in their
respective their respective support
systems he asks questions and gets
answers and they develop an
accountability and consequences plan
so i'm supposed to develop an
accountability and consequences plan
with the low life who flogged me with a
car antenna broke my eye socket and
stole my ipad what do you want me to do
next help him with his taxes work on his
to-do list
hell if i'd been mugged and beaten my
first question for my attacker would be
why aren't you in prison right now
but instead here you must work out the
thugs issues after all isn't it your
fault for having that money that he
wanted he was just taking from one and
giving it to another you oppressor
sorry the only restorative circle i want
to see is that perp encircled by his
victims and they're restoring a beating
on his ass
but here instead of putting the guy in
prison where he belongs we make the
victims his social worker
how would this work out
so i'm your therapist today and i'm
supposed to ask you how you feel uh okay
i guess i mean kind of tired
hey i know you
yes you mucked me in central park 30
minutes ago
took my wallet you broke my eye socket
and you cracked three of my ribs yeah i
know that's right my hand still really
hurts from punching you
oh i'm sorry about that uh my facial
bones are very pointy uh especially the
ones you cracked
it's okay i forgive you by the way do
you have any more money i don't you took
it all but as part of restorative
justice i'm here to find a solution for
your punishment wait punishment
sorry restorative healing how do you
think we should deal with you mugging me
uh well i mean i still have headaches
from all the high-pitched screaming you
were doing when i was punching your eye
socket
i'm sorry about that yeah um all right
well i guess i'll see you in the park
and make sure you have money next time
sounds good okay
so the people pretending to fight for
victims are actually destroying their
rights and ruining the lives for
everyone except the rich who will always
remain unaffected somehow i sense this
will not lead to prison time which of
course is the real agenda people like
this nut bag believe we shouldn't have a
criminal justice system that no one
should ever be arrested or incarcerated
they see crime even violent crime is
basically a misunderstanding
driven by poverty lack of education and
of course racism
for these crackpots the real victims of
crime are the criminals the people they
beat up or just instruments of their
attacker's persecution and probably
deserve to be mugged because they have
jobs or something according to the new
york post district attorneys across the
big apple last year declined to
prosecute accused felons at nearly twice
the rate of 2019 letting more than 6 500
suspects off the hook that's 17
that's not a crime what is i guess
that's one way to clear the docket you
can also reduce burglaries by leaving
your money outside with a sign that says
come and get it
meanwhile a serial pervert meaning a
repeat pervert not someone who has sex
with a box of frosted flakes
trust me they're not that great
oh yeah he's been repeatedly exposing
himself to kids but he keeps getting
released from jail thanks to new york's
lacks bail reform each time he gets
arrested he's out again in a flash
[Laughter]
[Music]
the scum has exposed himself five times
since the end of april this guy spent so
much time with his pants down in broad
daylight he has to put sunscreen on his
junk
five times he's done this that's four
more times than jeffrey tubin
two more exposures two more exposures
and he gets his own show on cnn
[Laughter]
according to the new york post this
flashing freak keeps getting sprung
because judges are largely barred from
imposing bail on the misdemeanor charges
i bet those judges might feel
differently if it was happening on their
street and where is the media in all
this well even as this summer has
witnessed a spike in violent crimes the
major news networks have spent less than
an hour in over three months covering
the crime waves that are ravaging 15
democratic-run cities
whatever happened to if it bleeds it
leads now it's more like if the victim's
a goner it's a yawner
and why is that well because the media
shares the blame if they accurately
covered crime they'd be exposing their
own culpability they pushed the funding
of the cops they demonized police and
they defended riots that's why you won't
see any of this stuff instead they're
all going to go in on january 6th
pretending to care about those officers
and those victims and throw everyone
else in prison no restorative justice
needed
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guest she hosts the
show after this one so if her ratings
suffer it's her fault
host of fox news at night evil shannon
[Music]
he's an expert on finances and
smoldering glances former director of
the national economic council and host
of cuddle on fox business larry kudlow
the only time he hears nice set is when
he's selling encyclopedias door-to-door
fox news radio host jimmy fella
and she's like my grandmother's meatloaf
only tolerable when covered in gravy fox
news contributor cat tip
shannon it's good to see you people keep
asking me if you're really evil or not
back to you they asked me they're like
what is greg's obsession with you and
your evilness
but i say i speak for myself clearly
people can see the darker side that i
towed around with me no no you're you're
an awful awful evil genius what do you
if you were the victim of a violent
crime would you want to work with the
person who harmed you listen if you've
ever been that victim or somebody that
you love you know the thought of even
going to court and having to see this
person in the courtroom it is
excruciating to think through that
process even if you want to help being
part of prosecuting somebody
i think that that's asking a lot of
victims and i don't know why we would be
giving deference to the person who
allegedly committed the crime um why are
we so worried about their feelings yes
and making sure this kind of works for
everybody if i get to pick their
punishment by sitting there across from
them sure then i meant that you're
absolutely right i'd make it very very
physically painful and very slow but you
raise a good question to larry what is
it about criminals that is so appealing
to the left all those stories in there
all were connected by that one thing
uh uh diminishing of the victim uh and a
preference for those who victimize
i think it's inexplainable inexplicable
because
this is woke gone wild
and ooh a dvd
nobody buys dvds anymore that's
but nothing happens because it's woke on
wild there's no gender you don't see
anything yes
that's the beauty of it actually it
covers everything imaginable
look defund the cops defund police not
enough no bail not enough let them out
every time not enough now we've got to
sit with them not in a courtroom but
presumably across the table
social workers good therapists good
police not good i think this whole
leftist culture of woke
every time you think they've gone too
far they go further it's a mockery
they're being laughed at the tide is
turning because this stuff is so awful
the woe crowd is like a stock looking
for a bottom and they cannot find one
[Applause]
speaking of looking for a bottom
jimmy ouch
jimmy i feel like we need new prisons
like you need a new wardrobe oh i will i
have a theory can i just can i throw
this out here i have a theory you
actually love my fashion but you're
jealous because it doesn't come in kid
sizes
oh i owed you one i owed him one no that
was good i was very good i'm glad you
came locked and loaded you were waiting
you knew i was gonna say something i
didn't especially with those boots it
had it was well deserved um here's the
problem in america right now we don't
have a crime problem we have a stupid
problem i say this all the time we have
stupid people that got elected and
convinced other stupid people that the
cops were a bigger threat to the
community than the criminals and when
you reduce it to issues of race what
they're completely omitting is that
crime is not an issue of black or white
it's an issue of right or wrong and
world politics often time make you
overlook right or wrong and it's gotten
us to such a bad place here in new york
you know we have these famous they're
called walking tours right they're now
called running tours because you might
get mugged you got to wrap it up fast
lace them up kids we're going to see the
statue the mess did you come up with
that joke in the tanning bed oh great
god you did it
it's going to be a chimpy show
that's why he's the king of late night i
think that's a self tanner
i don't know what it is
yeah
um you know kat i this is a tiny point
but i'm wondering if you caught this
when they had that example
of the criminal or the crime victim
right in that restore in her plan
they made it a male victim i felt like
because if they had used a female victim
to a violent crime and having her sit
with a thug they would have been laughed
out of the room so because that's i mean
that's the one thing they just they just
shied away from because nobody no
could you imagine anybody forcing a
woman to sit down with a rapist or
somebody who beat her up right but this
would and the craziest thing to me is
for years and years and years the left
was obsessed with
no blaming the victim right and
everything was blaming the victim if you
for example offered advice for how women
can stay safe then you're blaming them
if they don't do that that it's their
fault that something bad happens to them
this is literally victim blaming as a
policy right cause it's saying if you
meet with this team you'll know what to
say so if you had just said other things
you wouldn't have gotten you know beaten
with a tire iron right or
if you don't then they'd still go
through the court system then they're
they're blaming the victim for the
punishment this person had to go to
prison and suffer because you wouldn't
sit down with them it's like victim
blaming it double in terms of a policy
yeah and it was it also the the the
criminal gets to show up with his side
yeah so you're going to be intimidated
not only that the criminal is going to
know more about you this is you know
what this reminds me of this reminds me
of certain backward countries that force
uh the rapist and the victim to marry
you know after after a week now you have
to marry
as if that's considered the punishment i
thought afghanistan was the b block
was in afghanistan i can't remember
this
woman caban cabin whatever your name is
she'll be a natural on the city council
right of course
she's gonna win they're all crazy people
they are all socialists and they have
all these weird ideas here's another
weird idea i just got to inject this
okay today
the city fathers the education
department backed by the teachers union
has decided greg
there's no more honor roll right in
schools now i'm sure you are on the
honor roll when you were in k through 12
someplace one year yes last semester he
was obviously he was on aid
i must have been i just don't remember
but you get a trophy everyone gets a
trophy for showing up to school there's
no honor roll there's no merit there's
no motivation there's no incentives the
teachers are ruining the city just like
these crazy socialists who ruin the city
crime and education man that's the heart
of the city and they're just throwing it
away yeah and it's not just here i mean
we covered last night uh out in san
francisco they're paying people on a
pilot program not to shoot other people
right and they're also in california
talking about paying people not to do
drugs every time you show up and you
don't get a positive test they put money
on a little card for you and you get it
at the end of the program well we're
paying people not to shoot people and
we're paying people not to take drugs i
mean these are good ideas
and one note and that's not as out there
as it sounds in new york we're actually
paying meds fans not to shoot themselves
[Laughter]
there you go no honor roll
by the way if you look if you try to
find any research on recidivism on how
to um how to rehabilitate a violent
felon good luck because it's like a 90
recidivism rate which means you can't be
done which means you need prisons maybe
privatize the prisons they're not
supposed to have fun in there the
prisons are for us and not them hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else